I don't know man all right well whatever
we are alive again we're with rich you
inspire photographer and helping him
build the move to inspire people to live
better lives it's been a while rich it's
our last official hang out yeah let's
been going on give everybody an update
sure what's been going on I posted a
bunch of new videos a couple new full
interviews and some bits of wisdom as i
call it I've got a new a new playlist
called bits of wisdom so it's kind of
like bite-size pieces 1 2 3 minute
pieces of either interviews or other
inspiring videos I've made from Oprah's
stuff or you know ha yeah it different
different kind of inspiring moments um
what else has been going on I that's it
haven't been haven't caught up yet with
automating some of my stuff so I haven't
done much in that perspective may mainly
focused on the videos ok I'm liking the
videos ah i'm trying to remember the
bits of inspiration the ones I've seen
recently have been more your your
interview series yeah you know the other
one bits are done with them knew you
missed but guys on the team saw them
like the one of how to visualize it's
like a 34 minute piece on a
visualization exercise I forget the lady
that is doing it I'm going to see if I
can open it right now and another one
was Eric Thomas piece is like a 34
minute piece but that little story of
you have to want it enough cash on Marya
that's on my bits of wisdom that's a lie
oh yeah yeah the breathing one right how
about you wanted the breathing yeah yeah
that one live immediately i put it out
like Richard just jumping some out
immediately knows it
yeah what does things now inside my
comfort zone so they're easy hey back it
changed it used to be inside the comfort
zone yeah at least I'm honest you know
but step by step and doing things
outside my comfort away what else is new
since I think this is since our last
inspiring hangout is that put a couple
videos of me speaking German was the
introduction video to my my success
series success diary series and the
other one was um it was a little video i
did with you that little be Evan thing
yeah and you put that out so I'm out on
a couple videos here and there it will
be in a few more two more i'm going to
be recording a couple videos of
expanding the inspired by a song i'm
going to record a video about some of my
wild ideas about how to live and inspire
life based on my experience and what i
do in terms of all my alternative kind
of unplugged from the matrix kind of
living you know having my own toothpaste
my own shampoo my own all the hygiene
stuff like we created all of our own
stuff here at home but all basically are
weird eccentric lifestyle gonna start
sharing some of that wednesday tomorrow
is gonna be one I like that Evan you put
in the pressure on huh what tomorrow is
is being released at tomorrow you're
filming it you know what I'm gonna
record it and probably release it to uh
if I keep it simple i'll be able to
release it if i don't have if i decide
not to go and do a whole example if
let's say i do the one on the lemon that
you know of if if i just talked about
the idea then I could just release it
but if I have to find the Sun i also
want to kind of show how to do it and
take a lemon and cut it up that's gonna
take some more work in editing so maybe
I'll do that as a separate video later
maybe tomorrow I'll just kind of do an
introduction to my lifestyle what do you
think should i do like an introduction
video and then go to the the individual
things will go straight into individual
things so were you hoping to do it
you know just talking about laminar
you're going to do like I'm a multi-part
series I figure it'll be like a
multi-part series like I'll every week
or whenever i'll share something else
that's kind of eccentric and but is
useful to live in because you know my
whole idea with inspires how to live and
inspire life where it's something that
helps you admit your life easier rather
than adding more things to life and
making life more complex like I'm always
looking for ways to make life easier and
more comfortable and more natural rather
than adding more things to buy or do or
go you know like it's more about
reducing and becoming simpler and
becoming more natural I'm liking it I
mean I'm feeling new rich by there's a
calm there's a just a naturalness which
is great even if you think if you look
back on the former calls wasn't there
there's still a lot of luck walls and
guarded and this yeah I'm loving it um
what would be great steve is this is
this is new on your channel right nobody
knows this about no it's not no nobody
knows it's not no mention of it and so
what I what I'm thinking is you start
off with bits of what you just talked
about like why this is important to you
what it means so you know Jessica hablo
word those are both here together for
the odds life right but up there so I
guess it's in the room um you know you
have the inspired life like what does
that mean to you what's the inspired
like yeah when you talk about some of
the points where it's instead of buying
stuff you're making it on your own and
it's healthy here and whatever like you
have your me you want to get excited
about it passion about it um so you said
what is the inspired life and then you
can give some examples how you livin
inspired what okay and you can talk high
level oh my god 30 seconds to a minute
on each I don't know how many things you
have how many things we how many things
you're going to talk about five paying
seven things
I don't know I didn't it didn't you know
I didn't think it through there's so
many things like we're pretty much weird
on every angle you know from school to
food to water even the air to hygiene
stuff thinking stuff to environment to
people like on every level we're kind of
unique so then what might be cool to
break down what those levels are how
many levels this and instead of doing a
video on you know you don't share like
for hygiene examples and then what about
the school like if this is the big one
this is the what an inspired life looks
like break it down into your different
buckets so I gene is one swollen is 1a
environment don't fret your work you
know like break all those things down
yeah whatever the most whatever the top
you know top five o'clock seven things
are for you and then a quick story about
each one so hygiene you can talk about
that could be its own you know three
hour long video if you're going to go in
to dinner but everything you do and why
and how right so you know if you're
talking with a hiking point quick hit
overview about how to live in inspired
life through hygiene and then one really
tiny quick example if it's the lemon
juice or the ice buckets or whatever ah
yeah you remember that I forget about
that part too I feel like there's a lot
more but what it know there is if I'm
just concerned it's gonna be a long
video even if I do a high level overview
if I give one example in each area it's
gonna be please click in my mind 5 to 7
10 minutes sauna maybe I can kind of
talk about it as a concept and then
break it down what do you think because
OH like five min 57 minutes per freak no
no no for the whole big long that's fine
yeah video is entire yeah okay I was
thinking in the one or two minute realm
no it's not enough no it isn't enough
okay you're giving them a taste of each
one
and you know and I found that when I
hurt you you started you drop these
things a little bit you drop like the
lemon juice is yoder anthem and you drop
the Tommy Matt's sleeping on for your
kids and it's like what and it's it
draws out interest and curiosity right
it makes me want to learn one and then
that may lead to another video where you
only talk about each one of those things
but you know there are other things too
that you know why you move to where you
move right and how you raise your kids
and how you now we definitely have one
around your business too because your
your lifestyle choice to be an
entrepreneur and you know follow your
passions do what you're doing is also i
think would be important part of living
in our life okay if you really inspired
if you're you know working at this job
that you hate and you're coming home
every day pissed off and angry and kind
of living for the weekends and evenings
right yeah um so if you're looking at
different areas like family help
whatever it is um what introduction as
to why this all is important touch on
each one with one quick example so if
you're talking about hygiene you want to
kind of summarize your thoughts on what
inspired when is what an inspired life
through hygiene means to you maybe means
not going on in buying commercial
products all the time if you've learned
into the be sustainable and make your
own stuff maybe it's not putting
chemicals on your body and and being
more natural whatever it is like yeah
I'm putting words you know you wanna it
has to come from rich's heart here long
important about hygiene and then you
could say you can even named up a couple
of them right like I use lemon juice at
the order of and I ice bucket showers
and I do whatever right like wow this
wild like you're blowing my mind with
this stuff and that could leave the
comments that could lead to future
videos talking about each one of those
things a lot of my videos I get requests
from because I I just name drop
something quickly not intentionally and
they say
that's really interesting that I haven't
how did that happen not be from the
Dolan video answering somebody's
question um so I think the more
important role for you is figuring out
what those big buckets are and how you
going to address each one really quickly
okay but five to seven minutes is a good
like I'm excited to see this video cool
yeah and I'm not even gonna bring it
through you I'm gonna go straight to you
to the door oh man it's just gonna get
posted but yeah I've got to take that
jump right you you encourage that cuz I
want to go run it through your filter
first but I'm like okay i love it well
now take it take the ride it's a new
bridge ladies and gentlemen it's a new
year than straight reborn I love it I
love it uh well once a brainstorm like
what you got to do this for what are the
one of the main areas that you want to
be able to cover off tomorrow well one
kind of like the whole concept the idea
of kind of thinking for yourself because
we're born raised and kind of brought
into this way of living where you're
taught things from very young age of
this is the way things are and period
and you know it takes some time for you
to kind of clue in that you can kind of
think for yourself and figure everything
out for yourself and most of the stuff
if you do that you find that most of the
stuff you've been told is either not
relevant anymore was alive from the
beginning or you know concept that's no
longer so you kind of figure out okay i
gotta basically retrain myself on
everything from the basics of eating to
thinking to living dead so the constant
I mean that something that happened to
me it kind of dawned on me at one point
when I came to really low point of
almost dying that I realized I had to
figure everything out for myself so from
that point I investigated every single
area of my life and that's how i started
to be so eccentric on every aspect from
hygiene to eating to thinking to
showering to the people in my life so
maybe I'll start there from the concept
the idea that it's not something that
you need to figure out it's a it's like
a stew
cert martial arts that are very
technique based you got to learn this
move or that moving these combinations
when there's other forms of martial art
where its concept based once you
understand the idea you make it up as
you go okay how did you almost die
that's what stuck aha all right I what
what I i had this pneumonia this one i
mean i had a pretty wild past when i was
younger so I was going pretty wild and
pretty hard for a while and I got
pneumonia and it was misdiagnosed for
like three or four weeks and it just got
so bad that I was pretty much chewing
tylenol extra strength but four or five
times a day like nothing I was but I
basically went through a huge pack like
this of tunnel extra strength and a few
weeks straight and it got to a point
where I wasn't getting any better ended
up being in a hospital with a 41 degree
fever I was pretty much already
hallucinating my brain was about to fry
was basically one or two degrees from
death and then I realized okay obviously
in the end it took me a while to figure
out that everything was my fault and my
responsibility but at that time I blamed
the the doctors that misdiagnosed me so
that made me reevaluate my idea of
doctors being an authority figure you
just listened to blindly so from that
point on I started to learn and read
about health and and medicine and all
that and from that point that's when I
started understanding that you can get
10 different experts doctors and each
one of them will tell you something
slightly different and if you look at it
on the whole they'll contradict each
other so I realize that you really can't
trust anyone source you really got to
kind of get a holistic view and then
make up your own mind fist you get 10
different opinions from 10 different
experts all telling you slightly
different things so who do you trust in
the end so that's kind of how it kind of
started so from that point on I'm like
okay and now I can't trust anyone I have
to do my own research and figure it out
for myself that's how you start you
can't trust anyone yes cuz up until that
point I was still in the old mindset of
certain authority figures you just
believe blindly like doctors parent
so that all my teachers whatever so it's
kind of a foolish concept but you know
everyone has their own wake up moment or
moment of realization that was mine yeah
that's great this is a great um Steve
Jobs video that's similar I don't you
seen him actually posting on my channel
plus where he was saying about the
secrets of life is that you know you're
taught to live in this box and the non
typical nerves and just a state where we
realize that life is made up of things
that other people just created and there
no smarter than you you can go and make
those changes yourself it's it's
life-changing and so that's great so now
what you got to do is take that message
and crunch it down to a minute like all
of that that power that you know even a
quick story but that that you know
you're saying the same thing in a couple
different ways you want to say it once
once you regretted it it's okay like
it's a skill you learn it it'll come
with practice but that's that's your
opening minute and that's the best
preamble to how to then live an inspired
life and how you live an inspired life
um I like I liked are my favorite part
in there was when you were talking about
there are people in authority who you
feel like you're supposed to listen to
but in reality maybe you shouldn't be
like doctors and teachers and lawyers or
that you know whatever it would and it's
not that that like that the message
really stuck out to me was more the
conviction that you said it with it felt
like it really meant something to you
saying that Wow and so I want you to try
to channel that emotion when you're
making the video not how to stay like
high level but try to get into something
like that use words that that are really
meaningful to you I make a huge
difference for but the quality of the
video that ends up coming out so that
that's like that's the intro to your
inspired living great
now so you have this you cute ization
you know your life was change you almost
died you now you have no respect for
authority you're going to figure it all
out on your own you know that the bullet
would have been pull over like you can
see the world now so for people who are
saying yeah I agree like I'm rich it's
awesome I'm on board you know I feel the
same way I my own story uh what do i do
like what's my what's now that I've
understood this what's my next step
until those are going to be your your
five to seven points here's how to live
an inspired life um you know I don't
know mindset is is one of the points or
bats that's the first step like you need
to have that mindset before you can
before you can dive in on the points or
is that one of the points that you have
to constantly remind yourself of in
daily life is it is that what do you
find I mean you know what do you mean
well that that mindset of not listening
to people just because they're the
experts and thank you for your outfit
was it something that once you
discovered it you were changed rich was
changed and and you never went back or
is it something that use everyday still
have to remind yourself out but this is
important than this is why I'm doing
these things what do you find that well
you know what for me was it's as simple
as as one sentence it's who do you
listen to and whoever you listen to you
listen to an expert realizes it's just
an opinion you might be an expert
opinion might be a smart opinion might
be qualified opinion but it's just in
the pain the idea flew is the concept
was there are no facts in life well
there are some simple facts but maybe
the big things they're the facts we're
always changing like even in science
whatever the fact is in science at this
point or in the past hit had changed
with time the more information we get
the facts change so there are no real
facts everything is just an opinion
based on the information you have today
so which is something i didn't realize
back then and now that i understand it
so even if a dog
telling me something and he's saying
this is a fact then I can kind of step
back and say okay you're saying it's a
fact but in my mind it's just your
opinion based on the information you
have if I go and gather more information
I might be able to have another idea on
what the fact are for me so it's kind of
like the idea that who do you listen to
his starting point then the second point
is it's just an opinion it's not a fact
so okay but then the answer my question
that is that something that once you
discovered that you never went back and
you you you're a changed person or in
regular life even now you still have to
remind yourself that hey this is this is
a this is just their opinion is not
necessarily if I know I still find
sometimes I have to remind myself
sometimes if it's something you're
emotionally connected to yeah your
automatic pilot right away gets swept
away with the emotions and thinking
without how you need to have that moment
of detachment to kind of say hey you
know it don't get swept away don't get
worried or excited it's just it's just
an opinion Franklin for the most part
it's always there but sometimes I have
to remind myself how charged days i
would agree and I think people who are
trying to follow in your footsteps what
would finally relax and that you know
they may not support of an environment
as you might have with your wife and
yeah your friends and you can find this
environment for yourself um so that can
I would put that as the first step so
you talk about an inspired like and then
your first step is inspired mindset
where you have to remind yourself that
XYZ but you have to run yourself to stay
inspired reminded comfortable life on
your terms remind yourself not to just
take other people's opinions blindly and
so and before getting to like a
practical hey here's one thing you do
with hygiene like me here hit me you
know an emotional level um and I would
address mindset as as the first issue
over getting some comments oh yeah I
just have a comment new subscriber Evan
you're an excellent approach okay great
okay everyone British um anyway um yeah
so so so start with start with inspired
life what that means to you then talk
about mindset as one of your firstborn
say look here with a seven thing you
need to do to lube inspired line one it
starts really it starts with the the
inspired mind seconds if you worked if
you don't have that mindset you're not
going to do any other stuff that I tell
you to do right because somebody's going
to say you use lemon juice as if the
odorant that's never going to work and
you accept that opinion right and then
you're not going to do anything up so
you have to continually have that
inspired mindset um well the interesting
thing with me is I don't have to accept
that opinion because everything I do is
based on experience I'll take somebody's
theory or idea then I'll experiment if
it works for me then I make it my own
but if it doesn't work for me I let it
go so whatever I speak about I know from
experience that it works so if it
doesn't work for a particular individual
then maybe something needs to be looked
at because I know that it works out I've
tested at many times well that's the
other thing I kind of clicked into is I
didn't like I didn't want to be like
those people that talk about stuff that
they don't know anything about they just
talk about it because they've been
taught it whatever I talk about I do so
it's like I won't recommend someone or
something to you Evan unless I've tried
it myself and I know that it's good cuz
otherwise how do I know I'm just
recommending something to you and I say
it's good but I'm just a liar no just
blowing hot air I like it I'm feeling a
lot I'm feeling a lot bit like it has to
be real has to be authentic from
experience this is the rich man this is
the rich water capture on the camera
it's great alone okay so so inspired
life the start is par- that's the first
point what else what are some of them
I'm writing notes stole my name is
writing up what else
oh well what else not even in terms of
inspired work or career life I mean I
had come to a crossroads even though
from a really young age and what I
wanted to do I still had to come kind of
the terms with things at a different
point when things are hard or not
working out you kind of start doubting
and rethinking things so I had come to
those kind of crossroads as well only to
figure out again that I was on the right
path and I should continue what I'm
doing so there's you know my process i'm
sure you're familiar is probably
everyone many people's process of how to
figure out how to live and inspire life
in terms of career and that was a big
thing for me is how what how do you
question yourself how do you figure out
if you're doing what you're supposed to
be doing are you doing what is
fulfilling the day I don't that's fake
but what's okay so inspired career great
it's part of it is life take that thing
that you just said and crunch it down to
one or two sentences Baltimore um and
then it needs a short story or a quick
draw some ideas of how you struggled
with this and then eventually came to it
so that you have that in about a minute
or under so you have a minute talking
about the inspired career you have a
minute talking about inspired mindset
you have a minute talking about what
inspired family like you do a whole
bunch of things that your family that
are totally inspired and off the wall
and different yeah right but hit on
inspired help yeah what else hmm I'm
excited for this video man I want to see
ya am I think I'm gonna get inspired
well you will see a I think it will
unfold this as I'll get some stuff out
most will baby will start surfacing we
got a question okay from Alex who writes
in this is good this is inspired career
right here what if you haven't yet found
what you love to do
cool well this this is kind of was my
point is how I figured we figured out
what I wanted to do was like I said I
knew what I want to do from a young age
but I came to a crossroads in my life I
had to figure out if this was really
what I was supposed to do because it
wasn't working out at that time and what
I did in one sentence is a question I
asked myself if money was taken care of
if I was a multi-millionaire and now i'm
bored I've done all the travelling all
the relaxing what do I want to do with
my life in my time now and once that
kind of a question gave myself that
question in that concept then I figured
out the only thing I really wanted to do
was make movies and make pictures that's
what I would do if I was even a
millionaire daddy need to do anything
for money if I would do it for free what
would I do and that was it so that was
the answer for me cool I mean I can go
into more detail about it but that's the
short version yeah skill to learn so you
have your short version right so within
the seven-minute video that's 1.7 and
your or unapplied whatever and so it's a
quick high level overview and then if
you get a question or you can even do a
follow up video for Alex since you asked
the question take that a seven-minute
video to talk about it in more detail
and go deep or tell me about the pain
you're you know certain video then use
of God but you know one they're gonna be
money doing this use you beer off to
something else oh god that was when you
keep kind of coming back with whatever
your your turn your path that could be a
lot deeper video that I know I would
enjoy I think Alex would enjoy two and 0
everybody else too so I know we're kind
of up work with the clock um but you
know thank you for watching rich i'm
super excited man this video tuna are
and everybody stay tuned drop your
channel for the people or how do I share
all that stuff because I don't see the
questions oh it's in the chat if you go
to the actual you can go to my YouTube
page your people alive watching it and
then some of them are some questions
bola Oh
okay okay what is my freaking channel
well rich know what your channel is
before the next video yeah it's all
numbers and letters it's like weird i
haven't gotten my man you gotta love yet
everything's starting to coming off my
google plus page I now finally got plus
you gotta love so it's mine so my tooth
page eventually will be the same but if
you go to a plus you gotta love you'll
find my YouTube page and I'll have it
for the next the next hang up alright
thanks rich thanks for watching everyone
thanks Evan a great one